معنى من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد هنالك تحديثات في الروايه
الاسرائيليه تتحدث عن قناص
ما المعلومات المتاحه حتى الان عن ما جرى
منذ فجر اليوم وحتى استشهاد عنصر الامن
المصري عند الظهر
مساله القناص ليست مؤكده هي ترددت لكن من
المعلومات التي رشحت عن الجيش الاسرائيلي
تسلسلت الاحداث على النحو التالي الجندي
والمجنده استلمها مهمتهما في برج المراقبه
في موقع يبعد نحو 3 كيلومترات شمال غرب
معبر العوجه
نحو التاسعه ليلا نحو الثالثه والنصف ليلا
او فجرا كان هناك محاوله
لتهريب المخدرات حسب الجيش الاسرائيلي
وانه قام باحباطها نحو السادسه ابلغ
الجندي والمجنده قيادتهما بانهم سمعاه
دويه اطلاق للنيران في منطقه النقطه التي
يحرسان فيها وانهما سينزلان للقيام بعمليه
تمشيط لكن بعد ذلك انقطع الاتصال بهما
نهائيا ظل هذا الامر مستمرا حتى التاسعه
صباحا وكانت قوات تقوم بعمليات تمشيط
فعثرت على ج فيهما والاسلحه بجانبهما
قتلان وصريعان بالرصاص عندها بدات عمليات
تمشيط كبيره وتم دفع بتعزيزات من ضمنها
مروحيات مقاتله وقوات تم نقلها جوا الى
تلك المنطقه في نحو الثاني عشر ظهرا اعلنت
جيش الاسرائيلي على لسان الناطق باسمه بان
تبادلا لاطلاق النار قد تجدد في محيط هذه
المنطقه تجدد تبادل اطلاق النار ومن ثم
اعترف بدايه بان المصابين هم جنديان ثم
اعترف بان الجنديان جندي ومجنده وقد قتل
وبعدها بقليل اعترف بسقوط جندي ثالث
واصابه ضابط ضمن القوات التي كانت تقوم
بعمليه التمشيط وان القوه قد قتلت مواطنا
مصريا يرتدي بالبزة الشرطه المصريه هذا
التسلسل وفق ما ورد من معلومات من الجيش
الاسرائي حتى هذه الساعه ما تزال كافه
المحاور الرئيس نحو تسع محاور او ثمان
محاور طرق رئيسيه في المنطقه مغلقه
بالكامل من قبل الشرطه الاسرائيليه تمنع
الحركه فيها لان عمليات التنشيط ما تزال
مستمره بشكل كامل ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
الذي تراس اجتماعا امنيا لتقييم الموقف مع
رئيس هيئه الاركان وكان رئيس الحكومه على
اطلاع متواصل بهذا الخصوص قال بان الحادثه
امنيه خطيره جدا ونتائجها وقيمه حسب
تعبيره
وقت نفسه نتنياهو اصدر توجيهات الى وزرائه
من ان الحادث استثنائي امنيه استثنائي
لكنه لن يؤثر على العلاقات مع مصر وذلك في
اشاره الى ان لا يصعدوا من هجومهم او
مهاجمتهم لمصر كون ان هناك اتفاق سلام
يحكم العلاقه بين الجانبين غير معنيه ايضا
بالتصعيد على هذا الصعيد واعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي بان التحقيقات مشتركه له للجيش
المصري لمعرفه التفاصيل الكامله بهذا
الخصوص ونقلت بعض المصادر انه سيتم تشكيل
لجنه مشتركه وهذا امر طبيعي كما يبدو في
مثل هذه الظروف يشار الى ان هذه الحدود
التي تمتد بطول 208 كيلو مترات من ايلات
وطابه على البحر الاحمر الى منطقه رفح
المصريه والفلسطينيه
وعليها سياج امني تم بدء اقامته بارتفاع
خمسه امتار وبطول
241 كيلو مترا
ومزود بمجساد واجهزه الكترونيه كثيره
والكثير من الابراج المراقبه هذا السياج
الامني عاده ما يكون من الصعب تجاوزه لكن
بعض ما تقوله المصادر الاسرائيليه نقرا عن
الجيش بان المهربين مثلا
يستغلون يقومون بوضع سلالم عاليه جدا
ويقفزون او يلقون ببضاعتهم من خلالها كيف
تمكن المواطن المصري من التسلل هناك
تكهنات احداها تقول بانه ربما استغلى
احباط عمليه التهريب التي وقعت في الثالثه
والنصف فجرا ودخل واختفى ومن ثم اطلق
النيران على الجند والمجنده الذين نزلان
البحث في محيط برج المراقبه الذي استلمناه
فيه المهمه ومن ثم انه نصب كمينا ربما
داخل المناطق التضاريس هناك صعبه للغايه
والتضاريس ج بليه صحراويه وكفيها واوديه
سحيقه وكثيره التعقيدات
فيما يتعلق بالعمليه الاسرائيليه المستمره
عمليه التمشيط هل من ضمن ما قام به
الاستراليون
عمل اي شيء داخل الحدود المصريه
ليس هناك اي معلومات عن اي تجاوز للحدود
المصريه من قبل قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي
عاده ما تجري بس ما جرى في المرات السابقه
كان يكون هناك تنسيق بين الجانبين وهناك
طواقم مشتركه تقوم بعمليات تمشيط كل في
جانبها هكذا جرى في السنوات الماضيه وفي
المرات الماضيه جميعها حتى عندما تكون
العمليه جنائيه وليس ذات طابع امني هذه
العمليه هذه المره كان لافتا منذ البدايه
من ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ومصادره الامنيه
العاليه قالت بانها عملناها حادث امني
خطير جدا ولكنها
ركزت على انها كانت قد قامت باحباط محاوله
تهريب مخدرات
بكميات كبيره تصل قيمتها الى اكثر من
مليوني شيكل اسرائيلي هذه المره التواصل
هو على مستوى عمليات التنسيق المتفق عليها
بين الجانبين وفق الاتفاقيات الموقعه
بينهما وما تحكم به اتفاقيات كام ديفيد
فيما يتعلق بالروايه الاسرائيليه ايضا عن
الجنود الاسرائيليين الذين قتلوا
ما طبيعه اصاباتهم يعني هل هنالك اصابات
في الراس مثلا
اصابات في الصدر ماذا قالوا عن اصابات
الجنود او الاصابات القاتله للجنود
الاسرائيليين
الجندي والمجند الذين قتلا في البدايه
عصاباتهما في الصدر حسب ما ورد بعد العثور
على جثتيهما لكن الجندي الثالث اصيب في
راسه
والضابط اصيب في اطرافه حسب ما ورد من
المصادر الصحيه في مستشفى الشروق في بئر
السبع الذي نقل اليه المصاب لكن واضح بان
ما يقلق للسيده ويربكهم بشكل خاص بان
جنديين قتلا وبعد ساعات عثروا عليهما
بمعنى ان من قام بقتلهما بهذه الطريقه
لانه كان هناك اخفاق كبير من جانب القياده
العسكريه المشرفه على تلك المنطقه لانها
انقطع الاتصال بهما لساعات وبعد ذلك عثروا
عليهم خلال عمليه التمشيط وهم لا يدرون
لماذا انقطع الاتصال ثانيا ارسلوا قوات
كبيره جدا كوماندوس متخصص من ضمنه
الكوماندوز الخاصه بالشرطه وحرس الحدود
الي
ونقلت هذه القوات التي المعتاده على
القيام باجتياحات في قلب مخيمات الضفه
الغربيه نقلت جوا الى تلك المنطقه بسبب
بعد المسافه وهايئه كانت تقوى هذه كانت
تقوم بعمليات تمشيط واسعه ودقيقه في كافه
تلك المنطقه مستعينا بالمروحيات المقاتله
وايضا بالمسيرات
وكانت عمليات التمشيط على نطاق واسع وليس
على نطاق ضيق ولذلك كانت العمليه حتى هذه
الساعه لم يرفعوا الاجراءات الامنيه التي
فرضوها فيما يتعلق بملابسات استشهاد
المجند المصري
ماذا نشر الاسرائيليون عن هويته عن ظروف
مقتله عن وجود اين هو الان هل سلموه
للجانب المصري ام ماذا
اولا هم يقولون بانه تسلل وانهم قتلوه في
الجانب الاسرائيلي وانه كان يرتدي بزه
الشرطه المصريه وانه مواطن مصري في
البدايه تحدثوا عن ان بهذا النحو ثم
تحدثوا عن انه الشرطي مصري بحكم ان
العناصر والقوات المصريه الموجوده في
ابراج المراقبه القريبه من الحدود مع
اسرائيل في هذه المناطق هي اما من الشرطه
او حرس الحدود المصري بمعنى انها تابعه
لجهاز وزاره الداخليه المصريه الجزائريه
التابعه لها وهي الشرطه واحرس الحدود
ثانيا هم لم يتحدثوا هم نشروا له صور
وهو قتيل وقد خلعوا بعض ملابسه عنه وايضا
نشروا الصوره للبندقيه التي كانت بحوزته
والتي قام باستخدامها لكن مع التاكيد على
انه في داخل الجانب الاسرائيلي من الحدود
وهل ما زال هناك يعني ام تم تسليمه
لم يعلن بانه تم تسليمه حتى الساعه يبدو
ان هذا مرهون بالاتصالات بين الجانبين
المصري والاسرائيلي الى حين التوصل الى
روايه تكون على الاقل متفق عليها من
الجانبين لان هناك تناقض بينما ورد من مصر
وبينما يعلنه الجيش الاسرائيلي ولا بد من
الاشاره في هذا السياق الى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي كان في حاله من الارتباك
الشديد وعلى مدار ساعات وحاول تسريب بعض
المعلومات الى بعض الصحفيين الاسرائيليين
اصحاب الماضي الامني او الذين عملوا في
صفوفه في البدايه في محاوله لتهدئه
الخواطر في الجانب الاسرائيلي والى حين
ابلاغ ذوي الجنود الذين قتلوا عن انه تم
قتلهم والى حين استوضح الامر لانه لم يكن
واضح هل هو اشتباك مع خليه لتهريب
المخدرات هل هو اشتباك من قبل مجموعه او
خليه مسلحه تسللت ربما تساند المقاومه
الفلسطينيه او ما الذي جرى الى حين تمكنوا
من قتلها وتبين انه مواطن مصري وانه شرطي
مصري حسب ما اعلن